coming into dover harbor
another border force vessel towing the
latest crop of small
boats to have made it to uk territorial
waters
the authorities had been braced for
another surge in illegal incursions
as weather conditions improved in the
channel
among those being taken off the boats at
dover
many women and children more than usual
as mostly it's young men
who try to make the treacherous crossing
further up the coast at dungeness
another group made it ashore
again including women and children one
woman obviously heavily pregnant
across the kent coast we've heard of
increasing numbers of migrants
making it to these beaches like here in
kingston
they come ashore as i say anywhere along
this stretch of beach
that obviously dump the boat and their
life jackets
and then they walk into the village
either up old stairs road there
into these woods they take what the
woods look at these woods here and the
woods up around the corner
try to dry their clothes out and some of
them just brazenly
just walk through the village the people
smugglers are constantly adapting their
tactics
regularly sending out small decoy boats
to tie up
french authorities before then launching
multiple boats from other beaches
it's the cliffs along this coastline
that are the real danger the hazard
that migrant boats are trying to avoid
that and the often favorable currents
around here
has seen boats landing in increasing
numbers here on kingstown beach and
further down
on the beach at dale dover's local mp
is urging french authorities to do much
more to stop the boats leaving their
shores
it's incredibly dangerous and we have
already seen tragically
loss of life it's absolutely essential
that people do not
set off on this journey and that's why
we need to see the french
stop these dinghies before they leave
the french shores and
intercept them early and get them back
to france so that people
are not in danger the home affairs
select committee has now launched an
urgent inquiry
into what is a growing crisis around 3
800 people have been intercepted
attempting to cross
buy small boats so far this year double
the figure for the whole of last year
mark white sky news on the kent coast